what is a common misconception about  people's relationship to running that  you'd like to disabuse people of I'm not  a real Runner  invariably there's never been an event  where people don't say I'm not a rail  runner I'm not good at this I'm not as  fast as you believe me you're as fast as  me for starters yeah that doubt lack of  self-confidence and also lack of a sense  that this is an art that you can master  and that's to me is it and it's always  like a a real Pleasant shock to them  when we start to do these skills and  they realize oh okay I get I can do this  yesterday we're working as athlete in  Arizona and she's a dancer so she's  struggling to run and Eric stops he goes  hey show us a couple dance steps and she  clicked and he's like she just started  to bust out this dance instantly no  hesitation and Eric's like you're a  runner like that's it because her  dancing was this nice rhythmic bouncy  things like just move it forward and  you're a runner